[Aplausos]
[Música]
y por una vez los pronósticos se
cumplieron el presidente de francia
emmanuel macro no sólo venció sino que
aplastó a su rival marie en la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales francesas
hablamos ni más ni menos que de 16
puntos de diferencia a aproximadamente
un 58 por ciento para macro y un 42%
para l percivale hablamos de una
diferencia mucho más reducida a que las
anteriores presidenciales en las que
también se enfrentaron estos dos
políticos y en las que la distancia
entre ambos fue de 32 puntos pero qué
queréis que os diga aún así hablamos de
una enorme diferencia en un país donde
la reelección no es precisamente algo
común porque amigos la victoria de
macrón supone la primera vez en 20 años
que un presidente francés ha conseguido
un segundo mandato y la primera en más
de 50 años quien lo ha hecho dominando
completamente la vida política es decir
sin tener que contar con un gobierno y
un primer ministro de otro partido
distinto elegido por la asamblea
nacional la primera vez en más de 50
años
no me negaréis que se trata de todo un
tanto político más aún si tenemos en
cuenta que la reelección se ha producido
tras una pandemia o una crisis y en
medio de una enorme espiral
inflacionista y que encima la abstención
ha sido enorme y haber cuando quieres
cambiar o prefieres alternativa pues no
te quedas en casa en otras palabras casi
que podemos hablar de un nuevo rey sol
para la política francesa no es el líder
más querido y tiene fama de autoritario
pero tiene mando en plaza y si lo más
chocante de todo es que los franceses no
le profesan especial cariño de hecho las
encuestas de valoración habitualmente se
le tacha de ser arrogante autoritario y
snob seguro que fotos como ésta no
ayudan
y no sólo eso tampoco podemos decir que
su propuesta política aparezca
encandilar a las masas
en la primera vuelta casi el 60% de los
votantes franceses apoyaron a los
candidatos más escorados a la derecha oa
la izquierda de hecho su victoria ha
venido acompañada de una abstención de
28 puntos la más alta también en medio
siglo en una segunda vuelta electoral
está claro amigos que macro son pues no
levanta pasiones pero entonces porque ha
arrollado el presidente galo hacia dónde
se dirige la política francesa que
podemos esperar de este nuevo mandato al
frente de la france pues bien veámoslo
por cierto sabéis que el pentágono es el
edificio administrativo más grande del
planeta os gustaría conocer todos sus
secretos pues no olvides echarle un
vistazo al vídeo que hemos preparado en
nuestro canal hermano mega project y
además si os gusta la economía no
olvidéis echarle un vistazo también al
último miembro de la familia al recién
llegado visual económico que por cierto
ha sido todo un éxito en menos de dos
semanas hemos pasado los 110 mil
suscriptores estamos alucinando y esto
la verdad es que es gracias a todos
vosotros así que desde aquí un millón de
gracias os dejamos todos los links por
abajo en la descripción y dicho esto
continuemos
[Música]
porque macrón
ah
[Música]
el líder francés ha manejado francia con
mano firme en 2017 llegó al poder al
grito de ni de derechas ni de izquierdas
solo el mismo para intentar dar forma a
una nueva francia pues bien a lo largo
de su primer mandato hubo momentos en
los que su presidencia parecía acercar
el fin sin embargo siempre siempre se
repuso una y otra vez ahí tenemos por
ejemplo el caso de los chalecos
amarillos las mayores protestas en
décadas o incluso la crisis de la cob y
19 donde por ejemplo al comienzo los
franceses se encontraban entre los más
escépticos con las vacunas hoy el 78 por
ciento de su población está
completamente vacuna da un porcentaje
superior al de alemania el reino unido a
los eeuu pero sobre todo más gran ha
intentado modernizar el país galo y
cuando hablamos de modernizar francia
hablamos sobre todo de su economía
porque para que os hagáis una idea la
economía de francia ha crecido una media
del 1 por ciento durante los últimos 10
años y si en vez de mirar el conjunto de
la economía miramos el pib per cápita
bueno creo que una imagen vale más que
mil palabras atentos a este gráfico
en dólares internacionales los franceses
llevan perdiendo riqueza desde hace más
de 14 años e incluso si eliminamos el
efecto de los tipos de cambio y las
variaciones de precio el resultado no es
mucho mejor la producción de la economía
francesa apenas incrementó un 6% en toda
la década anterior a la pandemia este es
un registro mucho peor que el de la
mayor parte de los países desarrollados
es decir tal y como podéis ver la
economía francés ha estado prácticamente
en coma si tuviéramos que definir sus
números durante la última década siendo
generosos podríamos decir que son
decepcionantes y eso siendo generosos
hablamos de un déficit de más de 6% del
pib una deuda pública superior al 112 o
un gasto público desorbitado que supone
ni más ni menos que más del 56 por
ciento de toda la economía y un
crecimiento prácticamente nulo en los
últimos años la verdad es que resulta
difícil encontrar alguna estadística
donde las cosas se han ido relativamente
bien de hecho se me ocurre que un
indicador bueno puede ser la producción
industrial que en los países
desarrollados se encuentra en sus
máximos históricos y francia ha sido
tradicionalmente un país muy industrial
así que la pregunta es cómo ha
evolucionado la producción de la
industria francesa pues amigos de nuevo
creo que una imagen vale más que mil
palabras
pues bien para solucionarlo macrón ha
hecho esfuerzos por desregular la
economía y reducir los impuestos
esfuerzos que han sido muy bien acogidos
por la comunidad empresarial y que por
ejemplo han posibilitado que el
desempleo se reduzca hasta el 7% el
nivel más bajo desde el año 2008 y eso
no es todo entre eso haber también hasta
haber logrado que francia esté teniendo
la recuperación post kobe más rápida de
todas las grandes economías de europa de
hecho tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico era la única gran economía que a
finales del 2021 ya había recuperado su
nivel de pandemia
pero vale exactamente qué es lo que ha
hecho
pues veréis entre sus primeras medidas
tras ser investido presidente en 2017
estuvo abolir el impuesto de patrimonio
y entre esos grandes logros se suele
destacar la reducción de ocho puntos en
el impuesto de sociedades que era uno de
los más altos del mundo y también la
reforma laboral que facilitó la
contratación y el despido quizás por
ello nos resulta extraño que según las
encuestas casi ocho de cada diez
directivos de empresas francesas hayan
votado precisamente por emanuel macro
pero un momento no os equivoquéis en
cualquier caso hablamos de cambios
tímidos al menos mucho más tímidos de
los que realmente necesita la economía
gala pero eso sí de momento han
funcionado y esa es precisamente la
línea de trabajo que ahora se ha
comprometido a seguir entre sus promesas
está reducir los impuestos sobre la
producción para empresas y autónomos en
otros 7.000 millones de euros tampoco
gran cosa recortar el impuesto de
sucesiones y alcanzar un déficit del 3
por ciento del bebé para el año 2027 es
decir en otras palabras ajustes
discretos y cinco años más gastando a lo
loco porque amigos más allá de las
palabras si hay algo que a este
presidente le gusta hacer es gastar
bueno a este presidente ya la mayoría de
los políticos franceses
[Música]
tan solo desde que dio comienzo la
guerra de ucrania el gobierno francés se
ha gastado 22 mil millones de euros en
compensar a los consumidores y las
empresas por las subidas del gas la
electricidad o la gasolina todo a golpe
de dinero público y de hecho las
estimaciones apuntan a que las promesas
de macrón lejos de contener la
hemorragia fiscal añadirían 44 mil
millones de euros anuales más al déficit
del gobierno francés si es que se
cumplen sus promesas claro está sea como
sea lo que se espera de este presidente
en este segundo mandato es un rol
internacional mucho pero que mucho más
agresivo amigos macrón quiere lograr que
parís se ponga a los mandos de bruselas
y sin ir más lejos en los últimos meses
ya hemos visto cómo ha querido jugar un
papel muy pero que muy relevante en la
crisis de ucrania aunque no le haya
salido particularmente bien como iba a
pensar el bueno de manuel que no sería
capaz de hacer entrar en razón a
vladimir putin cosas que pasan el caso
es que ahora se da por hecho que el
gobierno francés apoyará que europa
establezca un embargo petrolero sobre
rusia pero sabéis que justo la crisis de
ucrania nos ha enseñado una de las
partes más volátiles y veletas de este
personaje esta es quizás la peor cara
del presidente de francia el eterno
oportunismo de parís atentos
[Música]
la cara más oportunista del presidente
galo
sobre todo y ante todo queridos amigos
amigas macro ha sido un tipo con suerte
y con la suficiente agilidad para mover
sus naves de rumbo cuando el viento
soplaba en una dirección distinta a la
suya el último ejemplo lo tuvimos
precisamente con la invasión rusa de
ucrania o mejor dicho durante los
prolegómenos de la invasión tal y como
ya os contamos en el boletín de patriot
y también aquí en visual política en un
pasado vídeo macrón quiso aprovechar la
tensión en la frontera ucraniana para
poner distancia con washington reclamar
una postura europea propia negociar con
putin y vengarse por la frente a sufrida
con august cuando el gobierno
australiano canceló un contrato
multimillonario de submarinos con la
industria militar francesa para pactar
otro con eeuu y el reino unido- y eso
eso no fue lo peor lo peor es que paris
se enteró prácticamente por la prensa y
que poco queda de la histórica
influencia de francia
[Música]
el caso es que en ese momento el
presidente francés dijo cosas como esta
los europeos deben dejar de ser ingenuos
tenemos que responder y demostrar que
tenemos la fuerza y la capacidad para
defendernos enmanuel macrón así que
cuando las cosas en ucrania se pusieron
al rojo vivo' macrón vio la oportunidad
perfecta para asestarle una patada al
gobierno de eeuu por eso en el mismísimo
parlamento europeo dijo exactamente esto
es bueno que los europeos y los eeuu se
coordinen pero es necesario que los
europeos lleven a cabo su propio diálogo
en manuel macrón presidente de francia
ante el parlamento europeo mi postura
común y reforzar la otan ni nada por el
estilo la unión europea tenía que ir por
libre para negociar con putin claro que
no convenció prácticamente a nadie
mientras parís hacía un llamamiento a la
unidad europea varsovia tallin riga
vilnius praga estocolmo helsinki
copenhaghe bratislava prácticamente
todas las capitales comenzaron a mirar a
washington y a la otan era desde luego
la mejor protección posible de hecho la
única posible y para colmo luego se
produjo la invasión estaba claro que la
respuesta militar era la única viable y
ahí la otan gana por goleada así que el
plan de macrón se fue a hacer puñetas
[Música]
y sabéis que ocurrió que entonces el
presidente de un giro de 180 grados un
giro que en cierta forma también ha
protagonizado durante la campaña de la
segunda vuelta cuando ha hecho suyas
algunas posiciones de la izquierda como
por ejemplo ralentizar el incremento de
la edad de jubilación o volcarse con los
verdes exactamente lo contrario de lo
que indica su propio diagnóstico
económico
akrón diluye la reforma clave de las
pensiones en un intento de cortejar a la
izquierda evidentemente el poder es el
poder y francia es francia tampoco vamos
a culparle de ello ni pedir peras al
olmo el problema amigos es que estas
cuestiones reflejan las grandes
carencias del presidente galo macraron
ha contribuido a mejorar francia sí pero
no ha protagonizado el cambio radical
que prometió ni desde luego parece en
disposición de hacerlo ahora la victoria
de macrón significa continuidad en la
política económica y también en la
política exterior y eso sí y aquí me
vais a permitir mojarme personalmente
aunque los resultados hasta ahora han
sido más bien pobres parece claro que
era con diferencia la mejor opción y no
sólo estoy hablando de marín de penn lo
cierto es que casi que podríamos decir
que la política de francia está a la
deriva
[Música]
política de extremos
atentos a estas declaraciones cuando la
guerra ruso ucraniana haya terminado y
se haya resuelto con un tratado de paz
pediré la puesta en marcha de un
acercamiento estratégico entre la otan y
rusia en interés de francia y europa así
como de eeuu marine lepén unas
declaraciones que se entienden mejor
cuando tenemos en cuenta este otro
compromiso le promete sacar a francia
del mando aliado de la otan si gana las
presidenciales amigos lepén sigue
viviendo a francia como toda una
superpotencia mundial que tiene que ir
por libre una superpotencia que tiene
que reclamar su sitio en el mundo y para
ello no ve nada mejor que mandar al
[ __ ] la otan y en cierto modo también
a la unión europea para impulsar así
políticas proteccionistas a acercarse a
moscú y hacer malabares económicos
porque le prometió grandes bajadas de
impuestos y pero también grandes
incrementos del gasto y que queréis que
os diga eso no suele ser una buena
combinación huele más a populismo que a
cualquier otra cosa como cuando dice
querer luchar contra la inflación
castigando el comercio internacional y
bajando el iva lo que impulsaría aún más
la demanda de las familias y con ella
los precios y vuelta a empezar pero
bueno ya sabemos que el papel lo aguanta
todo para que sois una idea se ha
cuantificado que las promesas del pp
supondrían un déficit adicional de 150
mil millones de dólares por año para
alcanzar un agujero total de
266 mil millones de dólares anuales un
agujero descomunal ya sabéis hacer
grande a francia o mejor dicho a la
deuda francesa
entre sus propuestas también
encontrábamos cosas como restablecer el
impuesto sobre el patrimonio
nacionalizar la red de autopistas bajar
la edad de jubilación a 60 años o pagar
a las familias hasta cien mil euros a
cambio de que tuvieran al menos tres
hijos todo por supuesto a golpe de
chequera pública y el cambio amigos
durante el siglo 18 francia le dio al
mundo los conceptos de izquierda y
derecha pues bien ahora este país está
liderando también una nueva transición
de bandos políticos que el analista a
reig man califica como nacionalistas
contra internacionalistas entre quienes
temen la globalización y quienes la
abrazan como una oportunidad aquí y
marine lepén es muy pero que muy clara
muy más izquierda ni derecha la
verdadera división es entre los
patriotas y los globalistas marine lepén
claro que eso en cierto modo es limitar
y simplificar mucho el espectro político
sea como sea a pesar del resultado la
extrema derecha del epen y compañía está
hoy más fuerte que nunca y de hecho
estuvo por delante entre los jóvenes y
la clase trabajadora el nacionalismo el
euroescepticismo y el rechazo de
inmigración cada vez ganan más adeptos
[Música]
y por la izquierda tres cuartas partes
de lo mismo porque el líder del bloque
de izquierda se un candidato tan radical
como mélenchon tampoco inspira mucha
confianza amigos la sociedad francesa
parece cada vez más dividida y
polarizada y si las cosas siguen yendo
de mal en peor en francia puede que en
poco tiempo el resultado de las
elecciones sea muy pero que muy
diferente de hecho en la primera vuelta
el histórico centro izquierda del
partido socialista francés se quedó con
el 2% de los votos y el centroderecha ni
siquiera alcanzó un raquítico 5% el
espectro político se repartió entre el
centro de macrón y los dos extremos el
mayor desafío de macrón será crear una
sensación de cohesión en un país
extremadamente fragmentado dará alarma
consejo europeo de relaciones exteriores
pero al menos por ahora hay cinco años
de continuidad
[Música]
y esto es precisamente por lo que la
reelección del presidente galo ha sido
también recibida entre los grandes
líderes internacionales de bailén hasta
el propio celesc y pasando por von der
leyen
felicidades emanuel macrón por su
reelección francia es nuestro aliado más
antiguo y un socio clave para abordar
los desafíos globales y espero con
interés nuestra estrecha cooperación
continua incluso en el apoyo a ucrania
de defensa de la democracia y la lucha
contra el cambio climático joe biden sea
como sea ahora se abre una nueva batalla
lo que se conoce como la tercera vuelta
macro lo necesita ganar las elecciones a
la asamblea nacional de junio para poder
gobernar a su antojo y que queréis que
os diga visto lo visto esperemos que lo
consiga macro no está siendo un
presidente revolucionario vale pero al
menos ha logrado girar algo el óxido
timón de la política francesa si puede
que no sea suficiente pero algo es algo
y en las alternativas no parece que haya
más que viejas recetas que recuerdan más
a los viejos mensajes populistas de
américa latina que a los países más
prósperos claro que francia necesita
tantos cambios economía pensiones
seguridad
en cualquier caso como curiosidad
resulta sorprendente los resultados de
las elecciones en los territorios
franceses de ultramar han sido
completamente distintos a los de la
metrópoli en la francia más alejada de
parís marine lepén ha tenido unos
resultados particularmente buenos de
hecho ha ganado en lugares como reunión
guadalupe la guayana o martinica entre
otros y en algunos además por una
diferencia enorme que ocurre con la
francia de ultramar porque parece tan
distante a la metrópoli pues queridos
amigos amigas de todo y hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en visual político
así que no olvidéis suscribiros al canal
si es que aún no lo habéis hecho y ahora
turno para ti qué piensas de los
resultados de las elecciones francesas
qué opinión tienes de manuel macro que
es que francia logrará de una vez por
todas remontar el vuelo déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y ya sabes si este
vídeo te resultó interesante no olvides
darle al botón de like una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]